greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by Balu Chu let me ask you something
how's that [ __ ] woodworking there in
this whole [ __ ] and pandemonium going on
pandemic whatever the hell they want to
call its focus it's tough to focus on
that [ __ ] flagpole of yours to get it
nice and hard when was the last time you
woke up with a hard-on in the last
couple of weeks the last couple weeks
you've been working like because you're
[ __ ] petrified it's all over
blue chu is here Joey what's blue chew
its the first chewable dick pill which
means it works fast blue Chu has the
same fda-approved active ingredients as
Viagra and Cialis listen it's [ __ ]
easy as [ __ ] you go online you follow a
few questions you sending me a picture
of an ID the doctor calls you back ask
you a few questions
boom bucho is prescribed online my
licensed physician so you don't have to
go to the doctor's office or weigh down
line in the pharmacy right now you got a
special order for the church family you
ready visit blue ChiCom that's blue
blue2 calm and get your first shipment
free it's that easy when you're pressing
code Church you just pay five hours for
shipping again that's blue like the
color of the dick van that's gonna be
popping out blue cheese dog blue chook
doc Tom that's it your first shipment
with code Church that's it you
understand me get ready to give some
women some [ __ ] stabbing cuz it's a
tough time right now you got to give
mama not even if your dick is standing
up you should eat duties to really put
her in Jupiter you want when you finish
you want her in the corner I'll shake
him like a runaway you don't want to
always find a runaway those dogs like in
the corner shaking that's blue chew
right now go to blue chew calm and press
in church alright the church is also
brought to you by stamps.com
everybody's avoiding crowds right now
but what if you need to go to the post
office you might be running a small
business trying to ship product or send
invoices but anything you can do with
the post office you could do it a whole
with stamps.com and I got big news
stamps.com is now working with UPS so
you get more delivery options and all
the great discounts on postage that you
used to with Sam's comm and ups it's a
piece of cake me and my wife been using
it for years
if listen only if you're that [ __ ]
stupid you can't use stamps calm it's
that easy alright so right now they got
a special offer for the church family a
four-week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale no long-term commitment to
contract it's easy go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and press in church that
stamps.com press in church the church is
also brought to you by expressvpn right
now you should be protecting your
privacy and security these [ __ ]
are home all day
trying to figure out your social where
you're born who you're from if you hang
out with Chinese people listen if you're
into Chinese an email you watch spirited
away on Netflix in Japan it's easy to
use even for a guy like me just open the
app change the location and that's it I
just got I love it it's tremendous is my
wife [ __ ] loves it the reason I use
Express VPN is this fast no buffering or
lag right now today the church could go
to expressvpn dot-com slash church again
expressvpn calm slash Church to get
three months from free for free free
free [ __ ] support the podcast support
yourself don't let nobody mess with you
go to expressvpn
dot-com slash church kick this
[ __ ] muley
the second surgery we go in like [ __ ]
the legend Stan Lee welcome to church
[ __ ]
[Music]
say bye yo
uncle Joey here [ __ ] saying hello
what's going on checking in with you it
was a boring Cinco DeMayo they see
nobody's getting pulled over nokton what
a [ __ ] bar in sync on a mile
I thought the Mexicans were gonna say
[ __ ] the coronavirus we're going [ __ ]
crazy another Mexican is one to control
yesterday which is good we'll give us a
[ __ ] it's okay you had a margarita at
home you kicked the dog you Chihuahua
cuz you know 910 mm gotcha Wawa's or
Paul had a pug cuz she's like I'm
extreme Mexican just in case you gotta
eat the [ __ ] thing it's less cutting
more the whole thing anyway who wants to
get into that happy Cinco de Meyer of
you're Mexican I'm sorry that you
[ __ ] missed it this year because it
was Mexicans don't give a [ __ ] they do
Cinco de Meyer it's like 4/20 oh they
finally were inside I do 4/20 every
[ __ ] day
yeah I'm saying I don't need to
celebrate 4/20 Mexicans live hard every
day George Perez don't bump into three
margaritas on the way to get eggs you
don't say that's just the way things are
white people they love slinko to my oh
my god it's [ __ ] great dick oh [ __ ]
you
that's good you're in that house minding
your business there's little chicks that
[ __ ] are drying up even always having
a bad time I know it's bad to be a
horror burglar is bad things are bad but
they ain't that bad uncle Joey's here
[ __ ] without the face man you know
what let me tell you something I watched
Ryan Sickler [ __ ] podcast today with
the face mask I'm happy I don't have to
worry no more that we're doing this zoom
because I tell you what just look like
the face mask what you looking at
to get entertained you reminded cuz this
[ __ ] guy's got a face mask on but
anyway talk this cheap [ __ ] let's
lock up a little number here get the
party started
a little triple extra urban [ __ ]
trees in Studio City it's like 30
percent killing [ __ ]
two days ago me and Lee ate at a I'm not
even getting a higher and the edibles no
more amazing me
it's a shame me and Lee saw me I dropped
300 right in front of them I went home
and nothing happened and drop another
100 I felt guilty
you feel guilty for eating animals out
you mean lemonade oh yeah it's just it's
not they're not working no more I gotta
go to extreme measures or just like I've
been doing just [ __ ] winging it
I've been winging it lately I won't I
didn't do a doubles for ten [ __ ] days
after I had my little [ __ ] breakdown
I didn't have edibles and and then last
couple days and we can slip a tube here
they don't do not no more it's open the
quarantine killed my tolerance inside
I'm moving on to bigger and better
things I got your deep deep deeper I
mean right now negotiations to bring
some heroin over from the Golden
Triangle as we speak some pure number
two white powder ma called me back yeah
oh yeah she had kovaydin I think she was
[ __ ] up there for a while too you know
Chinese people suffering too it's not
just us
speaking of getting [ __ ] up though I
haven't been able I haven't seen it yet
but I heard that Duncan's show with you
is amazing it's the best show it you
gotta take drugs if you don't take drugs
don't watch that [ __ ] show we don't
smoke weed are you silly or something
don't watch that show cuz my wife tried
to watch your show Messiah harder and
I'm right there in the beginning opening
episode yeah we weed yelling yeah Duncan
did a great job I'm very proud of Duncan
Netflix doesn't
I guarantee Nepalese put a second order
and but that's the mine the Duncan
Trussell it takes time that's not gonna
come up like be thinking shoot
especially 11:00 what's good luck that
takes time so Duncan did a great job I'm
very proud that he [ __ ] contacted me
to go on and do some of the voices and
help me out a little bit and watch it
what's never let me put something
midnight midnight midnight midnight some
[ __ ] this shit's got [ __ ] killing my
man anyway but having a great time
lately listen I told you guys I know a
lot of you guys are having the hard
times financially the midnight gospel so
when I got all mentally spiritually
listen we're halfway there
we're not the same people we were seven
[ __ ] weeks ago that's for damn sure
and I know your minds been drooling or
thinking of different things to do
different opportunities or what you're
gonna do with your life or if you even
want to be in that career anymore trust
me I'm going through the same
possibility you know you just sit at
home you know the I don't mind there's a
devil's workshop so I understand what
you're going through but listen you've
been through the toughest spot right now
you've been through the beginning of it
so don't worry about it
you've already know what it is to go to
bed hungry you know you know what you
went through all this so now you know
where you stand this has made you
tougher you're not the same person you
were going into this that you are now
you're a different person now do I know
cuz I'm a different person than I was
seven weeks till my thinking now I
looked at the simpler things you know
some chick at the [ __ ] park I went
bike riding and I know some chick and I
just went to pull the bike off and walk
and she goes you know what I do to have
a pool and I was taking my last week how
me and my daughter and my wife had a
blast with a hose in the front of the
house we giggled like [ __ ] [ __ ] I
wasn't even high I'm giggling cuz I'm
tickling my daughter I'm tickling my
wife with a hose like a [ __ ] broke
Porto Rican it's the simpler things that
you did at times like this makes you
appreciate you know it's not the [ __ ]
swimming pool it's not nothing this is
tech making you go back to be creative
with yourself you're sick of Netflix if
you're a normal human being right now
you've already seen every documentary on
Netflix you watch Joe the tiger two
times to make sure the story was right
you've watched everything in Chinese
French you're sick of Atria's you're
sick of things because now now you have
to be with yourself now you have to be
with yourself so the only thing you do
is put your thoughts on paper because
thoughts are going in and out of your
[ __ ] mind that the speed of goddamn
light is that like what kind of thoughts
are you having what you want to do with
your life this has to this is has to
wake some people up some people have
looked at this and said I'm broke
I got nothing coming in this is never
gonna happen to me like this again I'm
in a hospital you know I've been in here
for five [ __ ] days I almost died this
is never happening to
again you know carelessness not thinking
things out all these things are gonna
come to light during this [ __ ] period
that's why I'm happy I don't know where
the facemasks anymore
cuz when you watch me at least if I say
you as soon as you see me with the face
measure uh he's got a face mask on the
reason why I'm watching him is I like to
see a [ __ ] [ __ ] with a face
mask on so now I feel better than I'm
doing all these zoom podcast they're all
part of what did I call them my little
story some you know I got a guy on
coming on today Dennis Colangelo dear
friend of mine I got my brother doing
two episodes I got one of my criminal
buddies crawling in I'm gonna get I got
one of my bookmaking buddies from when I
was six and seven and eight they used to
run numbers with it's gonna call in to
tell you some [ __ ] stories yeah I'm
doing it this way so I hope you like
what I'm doing now I know a lot of you
people want laughter or a real guest
good luck try to get one you can't even
get your girlfriend to come over to suck
your dick can you imagine trying to get
a guest in these [ __ ] times I call
people they hang up on me cuz it takes
like I'm gonna ask them I'm just trying
to check in with you so I stopped
calling really yeah because they don't
think you call them for podcast that's
crazy
III would think because it's a it's a
creative thing I would have thought
people have been warned
listen know what it's not creative to
die I'm sure okay so when they're
telling you something you're gonna die a
lot of people don't want to come in a
little space and I don't blame him I
wouldn't come into this [ __ ] space so
we had to get creative you know we have
to change with the times and this is
what is easy I could get stuck kissing
here with a mask you know what it's like
to do a [ __ ] I would go home and my
[ __ ] tongue was brown like a [ __ ]
monkey
you're gonna zoom [ __ ] talking with a
face mask on so forget all that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] done with so what I'm trying
to say is with different people we've
accepted it you know I don't know if you
got a check if you didn't get a check
you know some people got it we don't
know what's going on nobody knows what's
going on the other thing we know is that
we're here to have a [ __ ] good time
smoke a little reefer and forget about
who the [ __ ] we are for an hour that's
why I could die and I'm learning [ __ ]
along the way I mean listen man in seven
eight weeks my daughter learned how to
ride a bike yesterday she fell twice not
once but twice
and I loved it she'll aren't too fast
one time she was running with the bike
and she went to jump on and she just
roll on top of it cut a little leg open
no big deal I tough from there up when
she got up and got back on the bike I
applauded her and then she was going
around the [ __ ] Park for a long way
and she took a dive and a little girl
came over and said your daughter fell so
I ran over to have my wife I almost had
a heart attack with the face mask on she
was bleeding from a [ __ ] her elbow bro
I got her up she looked over to the
[ __ ] thing and after ten minutes she
got back on the [ __ ] bike
I didn't say none - we got home you know
we work on the star marriage system so
she needed 20 stars to stay up till
10:00
so she was that like 17 she was supposed
to hit the Mitch yesterday for three but
I didn't have time yesterday we were
running around so much so when she got
off the bike and she fell and she got my
colleague and that's something my
daughter doesn't do what's my door she's
got a problem that I had once you're bad
at something she won't try to conquer it
but she was just gonna stay there like
she was understand there like one of
Jerry's kids and she was gonna tolerate
that so she got back on the bicep I
didn't say 9:30 we got home and I gave
him like five minutes take my wife
cleaned her up the blood and she thought
you know it's amazing the mind the
children I came out I said mercy Diaz
and she looked at me and you could see
she was respond to have a breakdown if
she thought she had [ __ ] up I go I
smell something in the air because
that's no I say either I smell a star I
smell a fart
you know saying so I smell something you
smell then she goes a star I go three
stars
she went three stars
you got back on your bicycle today
you're a [ __ ] savage I didn't say
[ __ ] I just called her a savage stuff
her face was red
she was high-fiving her father and [ __ ]
she was walking around like a [ __ ]
savage like let me do something so I I
hung out with the last night a little
sample pen oh and then
I went to check on like 10 20 and she
looked me straight in the face she goes
dead I made it to 10 20 as bad I'm the
evil dirty [ __ ] you always get me
anyway this is a childhood friend of
mine this guy the guys I'm putting on
here the next couple weeks are gonna be
guys that did for me did something I
mean a lot of people don't do for people
they were there for me and my mother
died I hope you enjoyed Stephen Villa
Stephen Villa came to my mother's wake
Stephenville okay my mother's mass I
don't know if he came to the cemetery I
don't think I let a lot of people God I
want my friends to see me in bad shape
Stephen Veloz mother if I could ask me
ask me if I want to live with them so I
hope you enjoyed Stephenville oh he's
still to this day a dear friend of mine
we speak every week we will have our
asses off and I'm hoping you up to these
people so you could see what my life was
about where I got my influences from I
hope you enjoyed that is Colangelo today
take a look hit it Lee you look shaven
you look beautiful it's a beautiful day
new jersey i heard huh yes it is yes it
is soon we'll be getting hit with that
[ __ ] August humidity so we only have
you know Joey May and June and then you
sweat your ass off half the June and
then it's all over
that's all you can't laugh you know I
gotta claw Paul's naked either one I
just was listening to Led Zeppelin whole
lot of love by Prince you put that up I
didn't even I didn't even know about
that Jesus Christ tremendous this
tremendous had to complete different
element to it he was a great great
musician he really was bro hours hours
the guy was just [ __ ] brilliant you
know yes he was bragging I caught him
back in the day in New York City did you
really yeah an 85
eighty-four I called him back in New
York 284 so he lucked out for 15 bucks
at the garden at the no at one of the
clubs me and LeBron Oh went to one of
the clubs and Wow it was what as a
prince nucleus and Sheila E the fifteen
bucks and the [ __ ] Tuesday night [ __ ]
can't go wrong y'all can beat that like
[Music]
[Laughter]
last time I saw you was 1983 before
Rascals like that was the last time I
saw you I looked for you I asked about
you I came back in 91 and for a week or
so and then I came back for nine months
in 93 and they told me you were living
in Newark for something like that nobody
and then Timmy Holloway he is later
found you he was the one that gave me a
Colangelo report I I seen Holloway at
veneris okay
there was a weight on my wife's uncle
passed and Holloway and all those guys
Edler they played baseball for my wife's
cousins Onkel you know he was a coach in
North Bergen so like they were old I
haven't seen Holloway I know I haven't
seen that look Joey I haven't seen
anyone you don't see anybody no I went I
went missing in action for a while got
hooked up with some wrong people like
probably like an 80
I even split away not even maybe a ve to
split away from Kevin tanner
last time I seen him I could borrow 20
bucks to go to Harlem to get a package
and like for a while there I was doing
some [ __ ] that you know you never should
have ever do and you know what I did
actually Joey I went back my parents
were living up on 59th but the senior
citizen bill North Bergen and I went
home and I told him I said look I need a
place to stay
I'm just and like my parents didn't know
nothing about anything nothing about you
know drugs not they didn't even drink
you know and I said I just need a place
to lay down I gotta get I got some
problems and my father looked at me and
he knew something was wrong I stayed
there and I dried out I got hooked on
the [ __ ] with boniva
I cleared up in about two weeks I went
to see Vinny ask Elise because now I got
where am I going
um you know I'm lost I went up to see
him and it was like I never left I told
him the deal I told my got problems I
need a job I need something about that
bath I stayed in his office Joey three
days straight he was trying to get in
touch with old high school friend of his
and he hooked me up finally hooked me up
with this guy he owned a trucking
company guy took me under his wing after
a few weeks he moved me into his house
with his family and taught me the
trucking industry and you know and that
was it I mean but I was out of touch
with everybody pro walk I just went off
the rails and not that like don't get me
wrong I been no angel you know I'm
saying I been that way I still get up go
to sleep quarter to 5:00 in the morning
get up at 5:00 pen and go to work the 12
hours you know I'm saying but that other
[ __ ] will just
just it's just that that was a bad bad
bad time but she you don't want to ever
see your friends you yo get embarrassed
you know really embarrassed it's you
know but anyway you know things are good
sun is shining happy healthy you know
life is good brother let me ask you this
yes I have growing up in North Bergen
help us how come he was so [ __ ] crazy
why is it that when you're at the shows
and I tell stories of how he grew up
people lose their [ __ ] Minds like it
seems to people that were from Mars like
when I tell my stories about growing up
people think about Martin I didn't meet
you till 78 right okay and you were were
you with Emerson at that point no I was
not perfect
78 I met you before that because you
were at McKinley did you play basketball
from McKinley yes gym shirt with the
gold shirt and you wrote your number
with a marker yeah yes had their
uniforms and we had the ref with the
[ __ ] glass I potaro but I still
remember [ __ ] going down to candy
school winter of 78 when it snowed a son
that winter and me and whitey shoveled
the courts yeah you came up there with
dusty there were some hitters Chris
Morano I mean Kelly school just had some
[ __ ] hoopsters yes it had to be it's
no like goofy the snow we shall will
bear yeah the [ __ ] Sun was out but he
was still [ __ ] 28 degrees the ball
wouldn't even bounce cuz it was so cold
bathroom and we would pass him so we
would like playing full court and I
still remember dusty going for a layup
and you went to block the shot
just lacked them by mistake and it was
cold out so the five thing is staying on
his face throughout the whole game and
every time I looked at him I couldn't
even stop laughing but who the [ __ ]
would he shoveled the cords we shall get
that good morning
we have a fog no no it was different it
was you know what Joey and like the
people we grew up with like they had
your back I even when we were in school
were in high school we're going out to
spark up grab a bite to eat like
everybody who would you could trust they
had your back like the teacher came up
and we're getting about no what are you
guys doing you're not supposed to be out
you know we just look like nobody would
answer I said I remember my freshman yet
maybe the second day of school
I'm downstairs where the wrestling room
the pit was they used to practice
wrestling down there yeah I'm with Alex
Garcia now it's maybe sector third day
of school
I'm a freshman don't know these guys
from Adam all's I know is we're going to
smoke to bone we go down smoke and smoke
and with with [ __ ] and we're smoked
and we're in school what's [ __ ] up
Tony cappuccino
comes downstairs SIA and whoever the
other kid well I only remember who he
was they were gone I froze like there
you know dear Nedley
I froze cappuccino was gonna kill me I
want to know who these guys were bout
that bag like I said beneath Pokemon I
said I'm here by myself you don't lie to
me he said I'll beat the [ __ ] on
teachers back then they'll slap you
around ha ha
beat the [ __ ] out of you nobody will
know I said you
i sat on them I said I don't know like
to me again he said I'm gonna knock you
out huh he takes me upstairs we were
walking down the hall and I was scared
yeah I was no [ __ ] I'm scared lonely
third day school we're walking down the
halls from Dalton comes walking the
other way
tabaqui no keeps looking at me well am I
gonna get those names I don't know what
you talking about
I said whatever's gonna happen it's
gonna happen I was alone he said you're
going down you're famous you're out
you're out third days for you're gone
whatever yeah we walked up the dog
thought looks at him looks at me I look
cappuccino goes what the f are you doing
here I said what he said what what are
you doing here he said get out of my
face I was wrong I said thank you very
much tabs the next class I had his
brother for woodshop
Ernie Irvan he already found out I go
downstairs or anything close to me
outside
Dennis I heard you had a run-in with my
brother yeah yeah he said you know he's
not like me he said I'm a nice guy he
said he really wanted to kick the [ __ ]
out he I said times I said we were doing
what we were doing I said I'm not a rat
I said you know I'm just I'm not a rat
it is well as if that mean gussy it
became really good friends like I knew
from nowhere and Papagena respected me
for it I mean if I was going down to
leech suspension whatever it is where we
grew up Joey you have each other's back
all day long all day long I don't
understand or today without in society
they turning all you like think I would
live and die for you [ __ ] when
I was growing up alone that's the only
way you get in the group that was the
only way to get in you had a they had to
know that you had their back
hey [ __ ] Z you know I think the famous
Dennis Colangelo story for me cuz my
mother had just died and you were my
entertainment you understand me I knew I
was going to school like well I want to
come home and you wanted there I was
depressed and we both had tortora oh yes
the old man oh and I had him in my
pocket because he hit me and Anthony Boz
Anna on the eighth grade so , and beat
him up so he came to me freshman year
and he goes listen you don't even need
if you don't want to come to homeroom
don't worry about like I got you so I
used to just go to homeroom to hang out
with you it was me you Brian to grow me
yes it was the DS and the C so uh-huh
who were in the bleachers next to me he
would [ __ ] ask you to our note that is
human come to school yesterday
we need a note and you go I'll whip one
up and you know what's the [ __ ] to do
like they just didn't know what the
Bilitis naw we had to know we had this
teacher Frank Rich he was a football
coach the wedge the wedge and you
couldn't call him wedge cuz he looked
like a wedge he looked like a [ __ ]
wedge of sass he was this sweetheart of
a guy yeah she was young he was three
days from being [ __ ] I both know
that and we went there one day they put
a ban on it he couldn't leave the high
school they were like you can tease for
lunch ever the way that's not happening
so we found out that there wasn't no
guards during the back door on 76th
Street
so you myself I think Jimmy and Devo
went to Fifth Avenue deli yeah we got
meatball sandwiches and listen there was
like a loading dock next to it this is
my all-time favorite and was sitting
there and that was in chocolates I weed
was big and we're bad thing you had it
behind you here
those days you would roll a joy and put
it behind me and evidence pool with the
joint behind your ear and nobody would
say nothing taking like not a [ __ ]
word so you had the joint by here we we
finished the sandwich will wipe on our
hands and all son [ __ ] wedge walks up
he's like hey guys good wage he he's
like are you supposed to be outside the
building you know whatever we just
wanted to get some fresh air and all of
a sudden out of the corner of my eye see
you take the joint out from behind the
heat and you start playing like this and
he's talking like like about whatever
like you know you know it's a nice day
whatever and also you like words listen
cut it out with sparking time we had a
spark and get back to class [ __ ]
like we need the spark or you get the
[ __ ] out of here
hahaha he just looked at you and just
walked away you know we used to you
played varsity yes and I was a freshman
and we used to practice in the back of
Horace Mann with leathers practice and I
couldn't wait to get out of practice
just to watch you because you would just
be goofing on people was you and juan
rodriguez god bless his soul yeah I'll
be Munez and all these guys but there
was this guy named Ralphie Moreno who
used to drive you crazy well I loved him
to death
Ralphie was in the wheelchair he helped
he was a tremendous athlete yes and I
still remember one day will I Dennis
will open up after practice to smoke and
Johnny like yet I'm just gonna take a
shower or whatever so made a bunch of
guys are waiting there and Ralphie's
yelling defense he's gone back and forth
in his wheelchair he forget you called
the timeout you light em up
you're like green oh say one more word
I'm a bunch of the closet Mokpo thought
we [ __ ] lost
he didn't even know what to say like he
even know what to say like we you know
now he go ahead problems you know have
problems he knew we all had problems you
know I had a we were good people
we didn't have to hurt anybody we were
just having fun you know there's a
difference you know I mean like when I
told him I put him in the closet that
wasn't the first time I used to take his
little sippy cup there he had with the
straw Ralph you want something to drink
and he shaking yet Danny said could you
please I'm thirsty and I just take his
stuff and move it further away from you
know and he had his hands flat on that
table lay out on his wheelchair and he
has he done he said really he said he's
gonna break my balls I said it was
different Joey you did today you talk
like that to somebody they lock you up
yeah it's a different society like it's
just we didn't mean like any kind of
disrespect or we say anything bad we all
want ralphing Marina I still love I got
a better better years ago did you
realize yes you know we didn't it wasn't
like I mean he knew I love them you know
I used to get a lot of smiles out you
know but he used to get annoying like he
said you can't get away with that [ __ ]
man he loved us you know what Joey we
made today we would do anything for me
we would we would do anything for him I
used to ask him if you wanted to get his
dick sucked and stop please just look at
me
a little Puerto Rican chick she wants to
suck me [ __ ] if it's Faceman turn red
Billy trate bit without the push him
around
yeah did a lot for him though Joe did a
lot of those guys help them on everybody
helped him out everybody was really good
thing that's that's really wish you know
the people would just build good people
North Bergen good people hard-working
people loyal loyal if they were your
friend then were your friend that and
you know it was no way you ever had a
collection huh that guy gonna stab me in
the back
cuz if any you had thoughts like that
about anyone they wouldn't be with you
it's it's just it's just different y'all
growing up where we up you know not that
you know I don't know I mean it wasn't
rough crape but everybody you handled
yourself I guess I mean I don't know you
just loyalty was big loyalty was big
with your friends and yeah that's what
we had that's what we had you know did
you even have a curfew
no no well we just used to be out my
father used to say I'm going to put the
chain on the door I said well put the
chain on the door well I understand
what's that going I said how do I know
if I'm coming home
he said I need to know this I'll be up
all night it's not worried about I mean
yeah I get the list bus used to run one
11 o'clock at night from 11:30 number
130 yeah yeah so you got to walk those
you know three miles downtown
sometimes I crash I'm back to beanies
house he lived right across from the
heist life yes yes he did you know a few
talk his mother would see me as we got
here whatever it's
twelve midnight clutter you ain't going
home like that no no you staying here
you know
then we drink some law I mean it was
different it was just different you know
another night I remember us in front of
Nick's pizza and you would go on camping
with Christian cabins Heather your
brother God rest his soul and I met you
up it first of all any party you never
went to a party like you never came to
high school parties no you like you
didn't have time for him don't if you
but if you came first thing I'm the
[ __ ] menu as we got to put Led
Zeppelin or instead yes take put the
keys upon the Kings put the Kings on the
turntable take one Springsteen we broke
their albums we just kiss a lot they
started yeah it's gonna [ __ ] start
yeah no it's not hold on but I still
remember a particular night where you
would go on camping cabin Tata you and
your brother and you guys were getting a
hundred hits acid for the [ __ ]
weekend explain to these [ __ ]
how we were remastered in 78 79 and 80 a
to cocaine took over we write decent
kids I mean we were doing it's acid trip
hurt nobody
we weren't hurt nobody bullying there
was loud but man when it came to
tripping and listening to music I mean
we just had and and that's what killed
us that we were doing great with the
acid and the beers from the reefer
things are great
nobody was getting hurt every once in a
while I'd go to that barn 22nd in Union
City and get the [ __ ] in the angel dust
that [ __ ] you snorted yes Justin going
to limp you know ah right right little
shuttle different 22nd and nutrient bed
something definitely just to break the
monotony it be 22nd and a New York
Avenue
but once cocaine came in that [ __ ] our
area
that's when who it was the beginning of
the end and we didn't see it nobody saw
no I feel 85
what's that we we got flooded with
Johnny
it was right across the front it was in
a town next door
right right remember we were surrounded
you know you had West New York Union
City we walk you got Jersey State I mean
if the Hoboken you had everything right
there in your area you know everything
was available everything was available I
mean we were getting it
we're getting here to THC [ __ ] my
freshman year we would drop down at the
bus stop at 8:15 in the morning don't
know the other side you know you know
many times I went to school tripping out
like that I thought I'm gonna skip
homeroom this way it's like you're not
in school today and I'll go to like two
or three classes and then I'll chill out
somewhere like homeroom for two three
classes go to practice you say oh you're
not in today you need to go home like in
no car slips I'm not here no clucks lips
today you know it's just that if I don't
I don't know how they do it but I don't
know what they do they don't even think
that will house these kids know they
don't leave the house they don't you
know Joey you go past a schoolyard
nobody'll hear no ball bouncing now you
know nobody's playing like that's how
like we all got to know each other you
know somebody's out there playing
somebody's got a ball let's go shoot
some hoops and we'll take her from there
but it's a different world it's it's a
different like if this virus came when
we were in school if we weren't it
wouldn't work cuz we would be out we
were out we were really out kids little
[ __ ] know nothing about going
out we were out from 8:00 in the morning
the Twala night when we were kids
have no idea of that that concept of I
push it on my daughter
I got a seven-year-old that if you're
not doing nothing you got to be out we
go for a walk we got to do something a
ride you know I don't want her to get
comfortable no in the house
no she goes to the gym yes she's taking
her karate classes or whatever
I see so you know you got her active you
know she's not sitting around playing
video games no that's not gonna happen
in my world cuz I don't
I didn't play video games no I don't
even understand [ __ ] video games no
fool when I went to a bar when I went to
a bar was to get [ __ ] up I wanted to
see the devil that was all that was the
goal there we go the devil there was no
[ __ ] there was no I don't want to talk
to nobody no I'm walking out of here
[ __ ] past that and we had all those
little pockets we had you know you could
start the party again Lee school get the
somebody's car then me and Joe Lucci's
house and God knows that you're gonna do
it Joe Lucci's house exterior you can be
up on 85th Street parts [ __ ] drinking
up there somebody robbed to be a trunk I
mean it was just our childhood was so I
look at my daughter sometimes like I
feel bad that she's not gonna have what
I had that special thing I had no family
growing up no no but I had you guys yeah
this was more than family that's what
these [ __ ] today will never
understand that we had each other at
that age yes you know our parents work
you know your pride yxg them you didn't
see them know it just a total total
total different ballgame
I seen um your daughter on it had to be
like toward Christmas I'm one of your
podcasts you had the Diceman on right
okay and your wife stopped by and your
daughter was doing some boxing right
yeah yeah yeah what the beautiful
beautiful very lucky I got a second
you all had a second chance we got yes a
lot of the people don't get that but you
also earned it
nobody gave me that second chance not
know how many times you drove somewhere
with a stack of bologna sandwich just
don't pick up 40 bucks at a show you
drove 400 miles or whatever like yeah
you paid the price
let's not you know beat around the bush
yeah you might be where you are now but
you you know you work for everything you
got no oh my god nothing not nothing
I left North Bergen homeless in 85
mm-hmm I ended up homeless maybe four
and not homeless living up on 88th
Street Park I was too embarrassed to
tell everybody this I didn't want them
to know I would take showers it mr.
Hayes house yes he would be home like
going I'd go to the back and I take a
shower and and and he judge Jeanine the
middle one would hear me and she never
said nothing nobody she would come down
and give me one of mr. Haig shirts that
would put on with mr. wonhae shirts and
I put a jacket over it and then I'd see
Mike and I go Mike this shirt look
familiar and he goes it's my dad's
shearing and they all knew mr. a mistake
you know they would they took care of me
as much as I could as much as they could
that neighborhood when my mother died
they [ __ ] rallied around me like I'll
never forget you see him at the shows
yep you see those same people at the
show people same people at the shelf see
I'm like I'm blown the [ __ ] away that
these are people that knew me when I was
a [ __ ] junkie like right left not
regular junkie you know I ended up doing
time in Colorado yeah you know how
embarrassed I was when the news got back
to North Bergen that I've been arrested
but that doesn't that that none of these
people are not our people are gonna lay
judge
on you we don't judge we don't judge
people we don't do that
Oh Joey's [ __ ] thief Joey did nah man
Joey's our brother Joe you take you for
who you are
if you don't like who he is then what's
your story what's your problem get the
[ __ ] out of here get lost
you know we all go true [ __ ] man you
know get lost you know what right you
see the same people like I see
danyoung see Joey I'm gonna be up too
it's the same people they never left you
you know they were always there they
were always early really where you know
really what man so these things you know
you you went you're not real tough tough
time but you're blessed you really are
and with the second with the marriage
and another child come on bro yeah God
gave me a second chance
actually you know what men you guys have
kept me so in tune like just talking to
you Keith aunty lubes of below you know
James I talk to you guys so I never fall
into this [ __ ] travel stuff yeah
this [ __ ] that they feed Johnny huh
I've always spoken to you guys to keep
me grounded you know by me talking to
lubes well he tells me that he has to
you know Mike Ronnie drives a FedEx
truck right my fat ass couldn't get on a
FedEx truck you know he's 57 years old
yep so when I'm sitting here going oh I
gotta go on the road this weekend and
he's telling me that you know he's got
to work overtime on Saturday I put it
into perspective
yep it gives me a [ __ ] perspective to
work with that I'm not unlucky I'm very
lucky
well it's you guys who have kept me
grounded over the year is that him
buying this jerk-off Phil they have now
the same
you're right Gladys yeah what's this
point updates
pick a time what happened I still see
you do you really yeah okay well you
wanna hear
uh-oh trigger turning thirty forty this
is my wife cuz my wife never updates
nothing but you still here brother don't
worry okay I can hear you but I can't
see that handsome face always [ __ ] but
we had a couple minutes anyway Dennis
I'm just happy that I got to see you to
talk to you because I know how busy you
are no I'm not busy it's a [ __ ]
quarantine ain't big going on I wanna
hear my friends on here I really wanted
to get all my friends on here so they uh
this side sees what we're about and if
anybody you're one of my early guys I
looked up to so I wanted to get you on
here you really made me laugh growing up
bro you really did you and Roger
holloway of the reason I didn't jump off
a [ __ ] bridge and I appreciate that
and I you know you always got my love or
respect brother brother this was an
honor to have you on the church what's
happened now I wanted these
[ __ ] to hear it from another
voice where I came from I was built and
why were the way we are you know I think
mr. Lisa I yet for all his help
hopefully one day uh when you come this
way you know you're bringing ugly Wigan
I'm bringing with me that [ __ ]
end up staying he fights a piece of bees
Chinese food that [ __ ] wall
meeting yet the newer gate the next day
I'm saying leave me posted give me a
call during the week I love you Joey I
like you brother stay safe you guys
alright you too thank you for listening
thank you for being my family I'm always
here got your brother love you love you
bye bye black
well back [ __ ] I hope you enjoyed
Dennis Dennis as a [ __ ] trip and he
wrapped it all up now you know what my
[ __ ] biggest weaknesses loyalty
loyalty has been my [ __ ] number one
killer but once I realize that I
shouldn't be loyalty then you gotta live
under the [ __ ] ground cuz I'm gonna
[ __ ] stab you ten times loyal loyal
will loyal to the end the guy he was
talking about Vinny they got him a job
then he was our football coach and he
helped everybody out he was a great man
mr. hey Paschal he's God rest his soul
that was crazy he got a job 30 years ago
and they're still doing it and it was
funny because mr. Scalise was the guy
who I told you the story about the
Georgie amico we used to rob the gas
station and he would always complain to
mr. a Scalise like come on Vinny you
know you gotta talk to these kids
they're robbing me blind and he was
always talking about me and raiga and
mr. Scalise was like Pauly from
Goodfellas he was like I'd talk with him
all the time they're good kids I talk to
them don't listen he didn't give a [ __ ]
you know he's like I can't stop you but
stop robbing the guy mr. a was a great
guy had a thousand meals at that house
I'm gonna try to get one of the ASCO
leases onto him I try to get Mike to
come on and talk some [ __ ] with us but I
listen they're starting to open up the
country me and my man over here the Jew
killer were talking about this to Christ
killer
it is a Jew killer this disease kills
Jews I don't like black people either
they made this disease like I'm a racist
but it's crazy they're opening up the
rest of the country listen you know me
I'm not gonna tell you what to do I
don't give a [ __ ] what you do proceed
with caution guys for some reason I
don't trust this since day one and I've
told you got another conspiracy Davis
I'm not saying anything like that
I'm just saying proceed with caution I
told you [ __ ] I told you
[ __ ] March
something 16th to get your money back
should I not tell them yeah I told you
[ __ ] you want any tickets to
any concerts get your money back get
your money back if the concert happens
scalp the tickets and you know you just
don't watch the opening band miss Joan
Jett who gives a [ __ ] about you know all
you want to see his motley crew and
definite laughter anyway so all these
tickets I told you [ __ ] tonight
you're crying to me online I told you
that can't get your money back we'll
make it work I don't want your money if
you're not if I'm not if you're not
coming to see me get your money back and
then I'll be [ __ ] playing about it I
[ __ ] love it I told you my just had
like ten friends of mine call me I
bought tickets for Rage Against the
Machine and they won't give you your
[ __ ] money back and it's criminal now
remember that [ __ ] so after these times
like I said a couple of weeks ago
remember this for after these times you
know I mean we don't know what's gonna
[ __ ] happen now but proceed with
caution ladies and gentlemen I don't
give up for the if Disney closed I ain't
going nowhere
this needs the greediest [ __ ]
in the world okay they don't [ __ ] around
they bang you out from A to C go to the
old town spend the night and see what
they charge you you go jesus [ __ ]
christ I'm not saying nothing bad about
Disney they run a great establishment
when you're a Disneyland a piece of
paper hits the floor they pick it up
besides that little ghetto fight that
happened last year I've never heard
nothing bad about Disney but for Disney
not to open up I'm gonna follow a lead
I'm a fan of Mickey Mouse and [ __ ] day
one well that's interesting you say that
because something you've said to me from
the beginning is that you look at like
how the top people are doing things
you're like just Rogen do this in his
podcast and no one doing this with you
follow their lead and you're right if
Disney the number one entertainment
place in the world says no why are we
[ __ ] around why are you sitting there
going oh we're gonna shoot this film and
mid-july you don't know what's gonna
happen me - I know we're living
day-to-day this is what's killing a few
people you've never had to live day to
day what have I been telling you since
day one I focus on one day one I focus
on what's in front of me don't tell
to be my next there's a lot next
Thursday that's why I started to hate
comedy because you want me to tell you
how I'm gonna feel forever worried 26 I
don't know what to do comedy Feb 25th
tell you I always hated scheduling
because I don't know I'm gonna [ __ ]
feel that's why I like the Comedy Store
because on Sunday I'll let you know I'm
gonna feel Monday morning I gotta calm
the commies don't go give me spots I'm
not now they're [ __ ] obviously closed
but when they're open you know so that's
why I never liked it I never I always
live for today what are we gonna do
today
are you gonna make money today I was
just telling me that we've noticed a lot
of moving vans around the area okay you
know welcome people are leaving at the
speed of light and this is only the
beginning I spoke to my friend yesterday
by Hudson New York and it's a it's a gay
community a gay town like the town
became gay yeah saying them bad it's
called Hudson's like Palm Springs yeah
he lives next to it he's a realtor and
he says that you can't keep a house in
northern New York
everybody's moving out of buildings I
said everybody's getting out of
buildings in New York City they're done
all you need is one thing for people to
start moving and you could see it around
here they're offering your free rent one
month they're trying to be sneaky though
they're making it sound a 13 month 13
month so be careful yeah but who gives a
[ __ ] there takes a bad number anyway
yeah you like the building on fire
what I'm saying is that [ __ ] you know
we've changed we've all [ __ ] changed
this has happened and I know that you're
sitting at home feeling weird maybe
thinking that you're thinking bad
thoughts maybe you're thinking the right
thoughts maybe you're thinking about
quitting that job you don't like that
boss maybe you've been thinking for a
long time about going back to school
maybe you were thinking about quitting
school because it's not getting you
nowhere and you're just mounting up
loans with the [ __ ] that's going on this
is gonna open your eyes to a lot of [ __ ]
seven weeks is giving you a lot of time
and wait till they extend it and you
know like I said I'm gonna keep living
life my plans are just what I've said
from day
but I have to stay home guys there's no
way I'd get on a five and a half hour
flight right now right now today there's
night I'm telling you how I'm gonna feel
tomorrow morning I don't see myself
getting up at 3:30 in the morning and
taking a 5:30 a.m. flight to be on a
flight for 5 hours to Florida or
anywhere right now right now I'm just
gonna wait for the [ __ ] these clubs
locally to open and work on my hour
again you guys don't want to see a
[ __ ] shitty Joe Diaz I don't I don't
want to go out there and be shitty Yaak
to [ __ ] around here with you guys on the
spot when it comes to charging you money
and getting you out yeah house and now
you gotta risk your life they go to a
comedy show I'd better be [ __ ] funny
or I'm gonna light myself on fire at the
end of the show that's the only thing
that will make you risk your life to go
see a comic or a band today so I've been
down I'm Bert Kreischer two nights ago
wrote that it's been I don't know 60
days 51 days it's like 63 for me Wow so
especially when you've been doing
something between nine years straight so
if you see me somewhere in June
mind your business you only do that
train right you go home and look at your
mom or thinking your [ __ ] brother
that's the same thought you're gonna go
get from seeing me we're all gonna be
rusty as [ __ ] so you pay $48 for a comic
in June don't be that [ __ ] dumb
you're gonna get what you [ __ ] pay
for we haven't been on stage for 60
[ __ ] days yeah there's some of us
that are so funny and she like that but
I like to be a little prepared I want a
little time you know I'm only gonna
charge like 20 bucks and bread in June I
mean July August September until we get
our limbs back and just figure out what
the [ __ ] is happening are people gonna
come out and want to shake hands are
people gonna want to hug are people
gonna want to take selfies
we got to adjust this [ __ ] so before I
got on a three and a half plane ride to
Cleveland or whatever I mean everything
on my pretty much is canceled the only
thing that there is
still open is July 31st is still I think
on the hinge August first in San Diego
and I know wiseguys is open and in Utah
Utah and I'm definitely coming you know
I'll figure it out
what numbers they have but besides that
I don't know what I'm gonna do a Philly
October 24th and I don't know what I'm
gonna do with buffalo December because
I'm an old man and that's a connecting
flight that looks slim if it's a
connecting flight you're in no danger on
our line right now they've even cut a
lot of flights so there's not leaving a
lot of direct flights anywhere they've
cut so many flights somebody was telling
me that the golden knew to land in
Newark they had a [ __ ] go to Chicago
or something like that now there's no
direct flights people are scared of the
five-hour flight on this so I don't know
what's going on so for right now I'm
gonna mind my business I'm gonna keep
wearing my mask I'm gonna keep washing
my [ __ ] hands I'm outlining the
[ __ ] book every time I talk to one of
these carriers every day I got a new
thought in my mind you know what what
what what book you would have got in
March and the book you're gonna get
today is gonna be two different books
and it's gonna be cuz I've gone through
so much these last seven weeks you know
from 9:30 to 11:00 the walls closed down
on me once my dirty wife's go to bed the
walls closed down on me they ain't fun
either guys I'm not having that great of
a time that's why every day I call my
single buddies and I add to the list
Steve deep delray [ __ ] Matt Simone
Lee my brother George in New York all my
single friends gonna call because I know
exactly where the [ __ ] you are you know
I know exactly where you are I know by
11 o'clock if I was single I'd be
pulling my hands out of my [ __ ] head
you yeah yeah he don't give a [ __ ] but
normal people normal people
Thanks I [ __ ] like man I gotta get
the [ __ ] out with that I cost you some
money there
pneumonia day he was delivering food to
old people he's doing a lot you know and
that's if not you know you're gonna lose
your mind so get involved if you're
having a rough time my heart goes out
you know I love you to all my art thank
you for listening what cloud you know
it's not that bad out if anybody's
scared of living it's me it's not that
bad out avoid people again and I'm gonna
tell you this for the 80th time and I
know some people can't avoid it
do not walk into a 7-eleven if you don't
want Kovac that's cold bit sensual I saw
it again the other day every time I'm at
the light I look him not the bad not for
7-eleven by the fourth wall that one's
not that bad but it's got problems
Reston ok you don't trust in me ok then
it's not me talking about how I I it's a
clientele more than the people working
late I don't I haven't been using the
same rolling papers these are rolling
papers we'd match gave me a shout out
the weed maps ice they gave me some
tremendous rolling papers I got I got I
ran out of regular rolling papers the
one I usually use but we'd map sent me a
little gift
a little gift package and they put
rolling papers in there and they're just
as good as the [ __ ] as to easy why
they whatever the [ __ ] I've been using
for the last thirty years so I've been
taking any like I need been taking with
a family but I'll just buy yourself do
you go on like rides really quickly I
like that you're in the car by yourself
as I do everything I can to make this a
lot easier everything I can and I stay
in the script every day it doesn't
deviate if it deviates it's by 15
[ __ ] minutes I get up tweet you
[ __ ] eat oatmeal take a quick
shower and I'm quick shower cuz I shower
that before
so does I get home at 6 and whatever the
[ __ ] I'm doing if I'm out in their
shower I usually would shower if I had
to go to the comedy store but if I'm
just staying and I would just shower in
the morning then when I got back from
training or boxing or whatever stupidity
I do now I always shower 6:36
I'm in the shower I'm staying it that's
it I don't want that clothes I had on I
don't wanna love my furniture
so I shower I talked to my wife and we
take the baby I live 15 we only have two
bicycles so we have to pick a parking
lot we have like four different parking
lots we go to and while they're playing
badminton I ride the bike and while they
ride the bike I'm walking you know so we
get that morning exercise and you're
like six wait watching points and in a
lot but it's better than nothing at
least I have something to work with I
dropped them off at 9:30 I go in for a
few minutes I sent some emails I do what
I gotta do
and then 9:30 is when I go run and do my
errands you know pharmacy before all the
other germs get in it
CVS Walgreens weed store you know
anything I have to go to if I want to
get cold cuts if I want to get groceries
I got a place I go to for them you know
I've been ordering food online just
trying it out I tried out Jimmy's
seafood doesn't say Stephen [ __ ]
tremendous easy like this [ __ ] I don't
think you like crab cakes you like crab
cakes
I don't know order them all the time but
I don't know if you like them so I
looking with mustard so I got like five
of them like they had like a starter kit
so when when Sickler told me ryan told
me they were having a hard time he said
they're running a sale when it's free
shipping oh so that's why I went I hit
him up and I got four crab cakes just to
support him you know my goal in the
beginning of this was to support our
local places we both agree we can't walk
into sushi damn as much as we love sushi
then you know we both have agreed that
we're not gonna go to cactus and when I
don't go to cactus that's one thing when
leader I'm gonna cactus you got a
[ __ ] problem
okay you know all our little food stops
I vowed to support them but because how
they are and how they shaped I can't I
still support the pizza pizza I reach a
wagon up Brooklyn
my daughter would kill me if I didn't
get it for her once a week if I didn't
get a pizza wagon a Brooklyn I go down I
just broke down for the first time in
seven weeks when Lee told me he ordered
gum shoe what's GrubHub which you know
you got to be [ __ ] that's really
that raises it that's an extra set of
hands touching your food on top of a car
that somebody sat on you always go pick
up your food you go to green apple call
them they'll tell you what time and you
sit outside and they bring it they put
in the trunk of your car
Wow okay okay so these are the things
you got to do you can't have the less
contact what motherfucked is the better
I won't hit a couple times I did they
had masks and gloves on yeah deaf people
are listen nobody wants to go out of
business and nobody wants to get fined
I wanted to truly support a lot of
[ __ ] places there's a lot of places I
go to now one of the support you know
there's a place I don't want to say
mention it I can't go in there they'd
lock the door you got to touch the
handle go in and Wayne I've seen people
do it I can't go in there
so my eating out days have been over too
once you told me about the that you
ordered then I go you know what maybe
I'll and then why we called my wife said
the Chinese people said they'll bring it
outside to you which in most parts of
the East Coast there ain't no [ __ ]
Chinese food Chinese people have run up
because people have been harassing them
there's a lot of Chinese restaurants to
the clothes because people have been
using racial slurs against somewhere you
know I'm not mad at anybody this was a
this is a punishment from [ __ ] God
don't blame it on the Chinese don't
blame her know that you know we could
blame this on a thousand things we don't
even know if what they're telling us is
[ __ ] true anymore yeah you don't even
know what to expect I'm not trying to be
a cynic or nothing
but we don't even know just write it off
it doesn't matter you know what man is
your [ __ ] grandmother died your
friends uncle died your friend's sister
died you know that's what matters so
somebody's [ __ ] dying I don't know
what it is I don't have time to blame it
anyway back to the Chinese food okay so
yeah I just got garlic fried rice
I was just the mood for something
normally you know any my wife is a great
cook
but he got for the point where
everything was starting to taste like
everything like the beef was started
tastes like the egg is the eggs you know
thank God I cut out the bacon [ __ ] 6
weeks ago and I've been just on oatmeal
because that gives me a different way to
work
I don't feel [ __ ] like I'm you know
I'm eating bread for breakfast
none of that [ __ ] you know we I just I
ordered the Jimmy's seafood and I was so
impressed with it that I started going
on different website so if anybody has a
great website like a restaurant tweet it
to me
just wait me like the date I just went
to Maine something company a friend of
mine referred me so I I made little Ward
as I ordered a one-pound bag of clams to
make spaghetti and clam sauce and I got
a one-pound bag of shrimp because we
haven't had seafood since this whole
[ __ ] thing started we had to bag the
shrimp at the house I my wife got a
Costco but besides that we had nothing I
was like and now we're gonna run out of
chicken or beef they're saying I don't
know what the [ __ ] is going on anymore
so I'm like you [ __ ] we live
day to day so I'm going online so I know
we got butcher block box but they were
sold out that's why we don't know when
reading their ads we did with getting it
rid of us we still got them on the
agenda they just waiting to get all
[ __ ] when this pandemic hit they got
hit right away right off the bat so we
still got them so hopefully once they
get back in action I'll support them
they have salmon it's all organic they
have great beef I mean the fish they
have is great so I ordered some stuff to
support uh-huh my friend told me that
there's a company that he or the seafood
phone because Burt turned me on to a
place but I can't [ __ ] find that I'm
in total Boulevard oh really yeah I
don't know and one three one something
jiffy caffee seafood company I couldn't
find it the other day I got frustrated I
ended up in [ __ ] in Encino so I was
[ __ ] pissed and I had a piss and you
know you could piss when there's people
on the street but when there's nobody on
the street
you just can't pull over and take a dick
out and piss because then people you
know people don't know when you're doing
that charge attention I had a piss in
the parking lot I had a make-believe
like I was on the phone get directions
and stand
my car and I had to pee close to the
door so I jump in the car like a
superhero almost broke my [ __ ] ankle
I would love to hear the calls Bert was
getting when he couldn't find where you
were going
I was pissed I called him twice
[ __ ] was sleeping and then he
finally [ __ ] call me back yeah
whatever
I go you [ __ ] I went up there and
I went home and check the website and
went and I couldn't [ __ ] find their
dad so something's not right so it was
my badge so I just ordered see if I'm
trying it listen guys I'm trying to
support the local spots but you know
well yeah I got my wife and I burger one
day cuz now you got in and out at 11
o'clock
it's a [ __ ] ghost town like that soul
stone song it's a ghost time you go out
11:45 the game changes every
[ __ ] wants a cheeseburger yeah
so I tried to switch it up for my wife
and the baby boom I got him [ __ ] in
and out and that's what I do when I go
out when I leave at 10:00 right and I
gonna run my little errands my mission
is also to bring them some type of lunch
unless my wife tells me I'm making this
for lunch already right so I try to
switch it up Thursday tomorrow is gonna
be a [ __ ] on your degrees oh yeah
starting Thursday you won't even you're
walked with Steve and I gonna be [ __ ]
he loves going as hot as fact you have
to go out he picks the hot guys you
can't you can't do six o'clock by six
o'clock you don't need to walk you're
dead I know your metabolism lasting 111
you gotta get the engine started Steve's
a good man you lose a great man baby was
my everything you said that's he's from
Philly he's Joe Frazier's nephew that's
all you need to worry about he's Joe
Frazier the highest Tyler that's when
you sweat the most all that [ __ ] jizz
that's backed up in your sisters water
all that [ __ ] humus all that fly sperm
in your neck oh that's no butterflies
out here this was sure because you're
sweating that stuff out that's the good
thing you some say it's a beautiful
thing
it's a beautiful [ __ ] thing with
zombie jover here anyway I love you
[ __ ] to death I hope your
mental states alright I hope you got a
check up somebody's helping yeah I know
I've been getting a lot of emails and I
replied to all of them
I'm which I'm going through my own [ __ ]
you know nobody is this [ __ ] does not is
not racist everybody's going through
stuff whether they show it to you're not
that bullsh Indian people are thinking
people are thinking about the next move
it's not just you that's feeling this
way I'm going through hell I just know
how to manage it at daytime and at night
once I'm home [ __ ] it I'll jump out a
window one way I land on the first floor
yeah you know it's no big [ __ ] deal I
was looking at my window yeah and I'm
like what if I jump out that window
nothing a few stitches I won't even go
to the hospital I'll just wear like a
helmet just go out just just to say did
someone myself it's one [ __ ] landing
I'm gonna stand on the legend scream
like you get all the attention I'm gonna
do it no no no no it's like that [ __ ]
girl yeah it's like my friend that's you
know I hate telling you guys this story
cuz I was gonna turn into a bit but it's
true I got a friend that forever she's
been killing herself
anybody have one of those little things
in your life like those friends like one
day you just go enough is enough I even
had to stop talking to her and I figured
she'd kill herself in the process but
now she ended up in the [ __ ] loony
bin two times but she never killed
herself so when this all started I told
you people I got a sentimental [ __ ]
part of me and I called a bunch of
people I haven't thought about Paula my
ex-wife that's how much of a sentimental
person I am so I just want you know how
many times they fed me a father and
mother fed me I thought about calling my
ex-wife and just saying hey man I hope
you're OK to this I don't want to talk
to my daughter I get it but you're
fought your family did feed me a lot
when I was a kid I just didn't go along
with it but I did call a lot of people
that I haven't
welcome to man and I connected with them
and she was one of them and everything
was great for about three days and then
always hour with the suicide talk again
not guys I'll take anything I'll take
anything you want to come and bring it
you want to test my wits come over here
and break my balls I'll laugh for you
but there's two subjects I really don't
want to hear about this three subjects I
don't want to hear about I don't want
you to reach for abortion I don't want
you to talk about [ __ ] Hitler in the
Jews and I don't want to talk what's the
other one suicide suicide and I don't
know what order they read i [ __ ] hate
all of them you want to crack a joke
about with me about the Jews you know
what oh you know what's that [ __ ]
stupid kid jump when you're a kid which
one I'm the killer
talk about yeah you know just I hate
what I want a month I'm gonna calmly
room and the Jewish person tries to
glorify Hitler that [ __ ] all those
little things I don't know if I've ever
told you this people but this [ __ ]
bothers nothing talk nothing bothers me
more worse than suicide talk I don't
know it's because if I had suicidal
thoughts with my mother and I push it
out I know if it's because I'm Catholic
oh I don't know if it's because I love
life the way I do and I would never even
[ __ ] consider it I don't know what it
is some people talk to me about suicide
that my dick just dies like my whole
body just freezes up I will talk to you
for a little while but after a while
either sit or get off the [ __ ] pot
you know either go get the mental health
that you need go to our hospital or
[ __ ] stop with this suicide talk so I
guess they took it to a hospital a year
ago I found that about I didn't call and
before this stuff started one night I
just reached out and she answered and I
started talking to him and everything
was fine for like three days then three
days in she starts with the [ __ ]
suicide talk you
on me I talk around it I don't even
[ __ ] justifier like I just go hey
what have you been listening to lately
and she would always assume you know
like she would always end up on it I
would call her and I knew her birthday
was coming up and I figured maybe I'll
do something nice for her for a birthday
bring her something you know but she's
so [ __ ] crazy that I know it always
turns into something else like it turned
into a speech or something so I've been
calling and checking up on her once she
started talking about the debt stuff
I've been calling and checking up on her
a car broke down there's a ton of [ __ ]
going on with a you know I can't put
down that because I'm not I don't go to
Hollywood as much as I used to but I try
to call it you know we were having some
cup because she takes all this
medication she sleeps weird huh sleep
was weird
okay so our hours or off so we didn't
connect a couple times then finally one
day I talked to Mike oh how you been how
you holding up and she's like well it's
taking everything I can tell me not to
kill myself or something like that and I
go you know what you really want to kill
yourself and she goes well I have no
reason to live I go before you do it let
me come down there I go what are you
away and she goes what are you talking
about what do I away I go what if I come
down there slit your wrists in the
handcuff you to the chair you probably
bleed out about four hours if you weigh
a hundred pounds how I know that is
because I watch the mechanic a few weeks
ago and that's the first scene Jan
Michael Vincent took Charles brought
this some chicks house for her to commit
suicide in front of him and then he
finally throws the keys that and drives
it to the hospital you should drive
yourself to the hospital and she calls
him a [ __ ] punk it's a it's a really
freaky [ __ ] Jesus Christ so what I'm
telling you [ __ ] as I told this
[ __ ] ran out I know if you want I got a
funny whack a stabbing the throat maybe
stabbing the lung listen that's right
told for that
who is silence on the other line
once you put it to somebody guys I know
a lot of you guys are gonna get mad at
me but think about it this is been going
on for [ __ ] in seven years she's been
icing itself enough is enough
if you're gonna take the die take the
dive you know I got an easier way you
know just AB use an easier way just get
one of those $28 tickets to a cruise
ship don't worry about nothing I'll take
care of it after that
well bomb it will do something we'll put
corona that will do something so after I
told you that I would come down and stab
her and handcuff friends you wouldn't go
nowhere like listen and it guys I would
never get away with it because there's
probably a ring somewhere somebody would
see me go down and they trace my calls
that you know he's my DNA maybe whatever
so I said that to it she thought about
it was at the time the girl asked me for
money and I thought I want to eat a
[ __ ] and she called me buddy just so
what you want to do when I go out but I
like your [ __ ] on fire and don't we
just do is just silence on the phone
that she goes can I call you back
same thing with this chick after I told
I would come down and stabbed her in the
throat man hopefully she'll bleed out in
four hours I'm gonna wear my money I'll
call you eight bodies in like eight days
don't get you in your nice and ripe you
know I'm saying when you when you kick
in the apartment I mean I just I just
drew out the picture for her because I
can't take it no more
there was silence it's so like three
days planned it was a birthday now I
thought I thought for sure his reason
Isis I want a birthday why I called her
and she was in good spirits and toys the
end of the conversation she told me she
was going to kill herself I said listen
happy birthday
don't worry about nothing if you want to
do it call me I'll be here all night and
she's up the fog and then the other
night I had insomnia what the Bennet
like 11:00 and I woke up the [ __ ] before
in the mall is the creepiest [ __ ]
thing you know we're gonna hear guys
creepiest [ __ ] thing cuz I told my
wife I opened up my eyes it was 358 I
put my head back down and
well I'm like I got a P and I went my
peed I peed on one of those long pees in
the middle of night well like you had
like a protein shake and 12 ounces of
tea like I always drink this warm tea at
night this thct dog I must have peed for
thirty five [ __ ] minutes I understand
that my wife comes in yesterday she goes
who peed in that bathroom there was pee
everywhere I go listen there's a long
story that comes with I got up in the
middle night to pee I peed I'd laid back
down again and I couldn't fall asleep
nothing particularly entered my mind I
just had insomnia so before I start
getting pissed off I used my own recipe
I go let me get up do a few bonnets and
write a little bit nothing's bothering
me you're like when you have to get up
and call somebody yeah no no I had to
call nobody
there was nobody I was mad at I had no
problems with my wife I just got up you
know and I get up I put my hoodie on I
put my slippers on I walk through the
door I make a left I make a right to the
kitchen and get a bottle of water and I
call my office and late do you know that
as I'm pulling out the chair by this
points like maybe for thirteen or
fourteen remember I called you come on
yeah I think it'll be later like 5:00 in
the morning right do you know why why
because as I went to pull the chair up
the phone started ringing the phone was
under like a piece of paper and also
heard the follows I'm like who the [ __ ]
is calling me a 4:15 so when I move the
piece of paper over its the suicide
chick so I'm like oh here we go she's
gonna jump the bridge right now so I
answer the phone I go what are you doing
up at 4:15 you I'm gonna come down and
kill you and she's like now I think of
it
she's like I think I got it rock and
roll routes Rob's got like 19 cases yeah
Hollywood so she went to rock and roll
routes so she's going for a test she
went for a test yesterday her answer
will be I don't know what the point of
this story was I just want to tell you
about my life and the people I have
around me and the psychology I gotta use
now because I just got sick and tired
and I told my wife and she's like you
should be ashamed of yourself
I am but I'm not because you don't take
those [ __ ] phone calls every three
nights when somebody kill themselves
most people don't take them they're like
I'm not gonna answer that call me I'm an
[ __ ] I take them cuz I got a [ __ ]
I feel guilty anyway I hope you enjoyed
the podcast today man I just want to
take your mind away for an hour just to
take you somewhere else from what's
going on in front of you I hope that
you're doing well I hope that your kids
are well up to your family as well and I
hope that you're taking care of yourself
most importantly like I said they can
open up all the [ __ ] theatres all the
bars they could give away free hand jobs
and a [ __ ] massage parlor that don't
mean I'm going I'm approaching this with
cautious and with common sense and I
appreciated you guys do the same I need
each and every one hears from Pablo
Angus even the Deborah lobster who's
been clean for 30 days how do you know
all you [ __ ] because you guys
keep me the [ __ ] together okay from my
man had him the V up and [ __ ] Toronto
my favorite Greek I mean you know I see
who you guys Chad reader I see you
[ __ ] and I appreciate you with
all my [ __ ] heart from the bottom of
my fat little toes to my [ __ ] big
gorilla balls that are not even on sale
there for free I calmly store.com
website and you can see my balls after
manscaped and the lotion the lotions
been working but anyway speaking of
manscape why are we talking about
manscape that's a whole different
[ __ ] show the church what's happened
now is brought to you by expressvpn
expressvpn is great for protecting your
privacy and sick
online listen you're stuck at home you
can also use it to unlock foreign movies
and TV shows that are only available in
other countries like take a spin on the
wrong side of the road and binge Doctor
Who on Netflix in the United Kingdom ah
where if you into Japanese Anatomy use
it to watch spirited away or Netflix in
Japan it's easy to use man my wife loves
it
Lee's got it it's easy even for a guy
like me you open the app you change the
location boom that's it you choose from
100 different countries Express BPM
works on any streaming service Netflix
Amazon Hulu BBC you to you name it they
got it the reason I use expressvpn I'll
tell you why tell them Lee it's fast no
buffering no lag Lee's sitting on my lap
he's a ventriloquist steam in age Sriman
HD with no issues huh I think you're the
ventriloquist anyway and it works on all
your devices did you hear me phone
tablet console or smart tv expressvpn
that's the way to go so right now the
church family gets X go to expressvpn
dot-com slash shirts CH you are CH to
get three months free that's it go to
Express VPN dot coms last Church to get
three months three months in watch what
you want and protect yourself with
expressvpn dot-com slash Church all
right it's going to protect your privacy
and your security online Express VPN
dot-com again we're in [ __ ] the
quarantine you look at your girlfriend
you look at your wife and you're like
what do we know we've seen every show
we've seen blue is the color of purple
we've seen ly what opal shame you're not
with Paula and you miss the office
reunion you could have held
and watch it like two little [ __ ]
things part that's not what I'm talking
about all right the church what's
happening now today is brought to you by
blue chew guys remember the days when
your dick was always standing at
attention anything oh yeah I do was just
breathing your dick bump right there the
[ __ ] good old days and you pull the
hair and you could [ __ ] jizz and then
put it back in their mouth and jizz
again now you got a limp dick
or at least I do you know I got this
[ __ ] week would ever since I [ __ ]
ripped my hamstrings but uncle Joey's
got the fix blue chew it's the first
chewable dick pill which means it works
fast if you want to give her a stabbing
boom
you pop a blue chew it has the same
fda-approved active ingredients as
Viagra and Cialis this isn't the horny
goat weed you get from [ __ ] Mohammed
down at 7-eleven this is [ __ ]
science all right
blue chew it prescribed online by
licensed physicians not some [ __ ]
Moop
so you're not to go to doctors office
and wait on line and then go to the
pharmacy and wait on line a nap this
shipped right to your door it's easy man
I did it myself
you answer a few questions you put up a
copy ID boom they call you back the
doctor calls you back with a few
questions and you got it at your door in
a few days like I said it's prescribed
online by licensed physicians and it
ships right to your [ __ ] door
the discreet package I don't even know
it was I had to it was a knife nobody
knows nothing blue chips directly
they're cheaper than the [ __ ]
pharmacy and best of all there's no more
awkwardness but Joey what's so good
about a chewable big pill what's so good
what's so good you can take them any
time day and night even on a full
stomach
and since they're chewable they work up
as twice as fast as the pill and they
taste good turn your [ __ ] dead dick
that's think it's like a [ __ ] monkey
into a [ __ ] hot rod you'll be
saluting the flag with your [ __ ] dick
you understand me so right now they got
special offer for the church family go
to blue calm right now that's blue blue2
calm and get your first shipment for
free joy what are you talking about get
it for free or you gonna do is pay five
hours for shipping that's all I ask
again that's blue like the color blue
like the dick vein that's gonna pop out
of your [ __ ] dick when your dick is
nice and hard I'm gonna beim and used to
get it and you look at your pinky you
begin you dick something you take your
dick on pop them on the side and it
makes that little noise you ever do that
those days are back again go to blue chu
dot-com right now and press in code
Church and just pay five hours free
shipping you'll thank me [ __ ] later
the church is also brought to you by
stamps.com listen everybody's avoiding
the [ __ ] crowds right now but if you
need to go to the post office what are
you gonna do you might be running a
small business you're trying to ship a
product or send invoices but I think you
could do it a post office you could do
it home with stamps calm and I got big
news
stamps.com is working with UPS now you
get more delivery options and all the
great discounts on postage that you used
to with those stamps calm and UPS my
wife's been using this is day one I use
it with her she goes to the post office
every day and ships
listen stamps calm his tremendous they
bring the post office to you you skip
the line you print the postage you slap
it on any letter any sized package going
anywhere in the world right there from
your porch and the best part is the
mailman will come and pick it up no
contact required it's that simple you
also get great discounts get five cents
off every first-class step and up to 40%
off shipping you can't beat that save up
the sixty-two percent on UPS rates you
can't beat that okay so do me a favor go
to Stan's comm it's a no-brainer
especially now you're saving time you're
saving money and you're just keeping you
safe so right now they got a special
offer the church family you get four
week trial plus poster
free by the way free I got a mention
free I don't want you to think that's a
[ __ ] by the way and I'm gonna throw
in a digital scale no long term
commitments no contracts it's easy go to
stamps.com click the microphone on top
of the homepage and press in church
that's it stamps.com
press in church stay safe mother [ __ ]
I want to thank stamps.com I wanted
thank expressvpn and I want to thank
blue Chu for always having our
[ __ ] back but most importantly
I want to thank you guys I want to thank
Dennis Colangelo and I want to thank my
man the [ __ ]
yo we'll be back Monday morning ready to
[ __ ] rock with some more Church of
what's happened now for right now I love
you guys with all my heart
remember stay loyal to your friends you
got only three of them you live and die
by them you can't go wrong I love you
[ __ ] have a great weekend stay
safe keep your [ __ ] distance I don't
want to know doctor its pandemic season
have a great weekend
love you guys kick it Lee
[Music]